so how do we fix that that's coming from
right how do we like level the playing
field there you're doing it slowly well
I mean to me it's like the it's the you
you get rid of the consequence more
people do it so if you pay women to
leave marriages the more girls are going
to do it they're paid through child
support and through the government
like when you pay women to make bad
decisions every bad decision we make
we're bailed out of you could be
homeless there's a women's shelter to
take care of you you could sleep around
you can get an abortion to bail you out
like whatever bad decision women make
there's a bailout there's incentives
yeah like like so if you're paid to make
bad decisions more women make bad
decisions like they're not going to stop
they're not going to stop till the
consequence goes away yeah yeah
what did you say earlier sorry there's
uh she didn't know she didn't hear it
and I said in my day you know women were
just gonna they're getting pregnant
together yeah yeah yeah yeah he's the
first time I heard of it and I said yeah
hit reality hard because if a man makes
a bad decision or if he ain't [__] the
world will tell him yeah well they will
feed women lies and let her live in
delusion like even even when I said
you're less valuable when you hit 30
like that shouldn't be that's just life
yeah like I'm less valuable than I was
when I was 22. it just is what it is it
is what it is it's not it's not a
personal attack on me yeah we're not
talking about personal worth but
honestly honestly honestly to everyone
like your looks are currency girls don't
even like we don't know how good they
have it because you are given more
attention and opportunity because of the
way you look life is on easy mode as a
young pretty girl [__] like hit 50 let
life change ever
but people still choose to argue the
fact it is true as a 21 year old your
life was different to how it is now it
is a fact
it is a fact when you were younger you
were more attractive you went out you
you felt fresher no it's not that mean
to me honestly no honestly I'm gonna I'm
gonna ask you something then
um it happened to me to have many
friends they actually prefer like date
older they're trying they're trying to
[__] you yeah
all right guys
may I make the point men are trying to
[__] you at 20 years old girl as a 15
years old woman that's not different
they are thinking just to
I don't want to be rude but like you
know I mean they are thinking about that
from the principle so if uh old women
get you know less attractive whatever it
is so anyway that's quite good looking
15 years old women that they actually
dating 20 or 30 years old man
it's not even the women not money no no
it's not it's not it's not even like
honestly me personally I add friends
very good look six foot guys very good
looking guys they actually dated older
women also child did they marry them
well what in terms it doesn't count
unless you get a ring for me like that
doesn't know what I'm saying it doesn't
count unless he commits to you for life
so yeah
I could say okay I dated a guy that was
a millionaire does that mean make me a
millionaire wife no no no yeah but
that's actually if you don't have
results the results so first of all
that's not the result for myself because
uh uh 20 years old women who can get
married when she's 22 so she's so
valuable or whatever she got a lot of
eggs she can be left alone when she is
25 and the uzban is sleeping around
around and gonna left her alone looking
after the child so what about the value
we're talking about she's still 25 she
give you a best life her best friend and
she is she is by herself now so what
about this what about this we're gonna
say why don't you get married before she
had the kid no no I said you getting a
20 years old women with lot of eggs you
know beautiful and then everything so
very you know childless
not childless okay so you get married
with that you get you got a pregnant so
let's say you got one child or whatever
now how many cases we know about men
leaving the house with the child
children oh men still cheating on them
cheating about the value guys if she was
available so why it went outside to
looking for others because because
cheating is different for men and for
women men can have sex with the phone
and what about when they leave the
cheese
no they don't know
women women women
stop yelling stop stop you you just are
yelling okay women leave 70 to 80
percent of the time 90 if you have a
college degree 90 of the time you're
leaving
Man by and large are not leaving so
that's not who do you men and women
cheat at equal rates I'm talking about I
lot of children left alone from daydad
okay I know a lot of single mothers and
they've been left alone okay you can you
can know it but you can look at who
files divorce the difference
but the difference from what she's
saying
is that the big difference is what you
said that he married her yeah that gives
her status who cares if he's sleeping
out she's covered if she goes I get
married that's what I was gonna say
thank you
guys the man sorry Auntie Jenny just
give me one second guys I'm gonna
reiterate the rules because we're not
getting there one at a time people at
home can't hear you it's a great
conversation I want you guys to have
this conversation but I need to be able
to hear you so please allow each other
to speak one at a time thank you let's
get into it you got
a young girl you say 25 with a kid
and the mama is a loser goes and sleeps
out you got a 25 yeah yeah you got a 25
year old woman
not married the man has a kid with a
loser who's at the better advice the one
that got married
yes
because she can take everything because
they're making everything about status
and what Society think about women
that's like me saying I'm an Olympian
with no metal
like like women live like this is what I
mean like you're like that's delusion go
through life living in delusion
if I if I have a ring then I am
protected I if I I okay okay your mic is
off because you keep interrupting me if
I have a ring that I'm entitled like
then I'm protected legally I'm protected
legally if you don't want from from
okay do you not do you not know League
sorry but if he you can turn it on go
ahead oh I was on mute this whole time
okay but if if he if he's cheated on you
like a 20 year old he's married her
she's young she's got eggs whatever dude
he's married her they've had vowels
they've had a child and he's cheated
she's okay because she's got a ring he's
racist
especially because he married her that's
what's the most important thing and then
and then there's a side chicken and the
wife I don't finish sorry so so you said
that there was the 20 year old who got
married had a baby and he cheated and
then you got the 25 year old who had a
baby but didn't get married and he
cheated or let's just say they're both
the same age right right the one that
had a ring is more special because she
got a ring she's more protected okay
she's protected by law because his
husband
yeah exactly so like let's say so so
because sorry I hadn't finished so
because she's protected by the ring that
makes her more valuable because she got
the medal yeah
results
and then you say I haven't finished no
because you cut in and didn't let me
finish okay go on so then sorry I've
just you just said the result was the
ring but the result was he she got
cheated okay cool okay allowed to finish
a lot all right cool no it's just like
they're both they're they're both at a
loss it's not one is better than the
other they're both equal okay well it's
not no no no it's not equal because
we're married this is my point so one's
protected so because she got married
she's protected by the law because of
the yes
can we be real about life I'm just
taking it and I'm not disagreeing I'm
not saying it to make it clear so if
we're being clear about life like you
said we have two women in identical
positions but one is married and one is
not if you're not married and it all
goes pear-shaped you're gone honestly
nothing you can't go nowhere and say
well he cheated on me I should get half
sorry love you're not married forget
about it if you're married you're
entitled yeah yeah in life let's be real
you're getting half okay cool I've been
cheated on emotionally you might be sad
for a bit but again as they say do you
want to cry in a Bentley or in a Fiat
Panda okay
you want to get cheated on and go and
stay go back home to your mum or stay in
a room with your friends or do you want
to get the house
talking first and men look at and men
look at Ex-Wives and ex-girlfriends
different okay so man look at Ex-Wives
and ex-girlfriends different because
because one has results and they can say
oh that man chose her she was worth
being chosen where a girl that's that's
over a certain age they're like why
nobody choose you because I know other
guys aren't stupid so why didn't anyone
Choose You So then the two women that
were both 20 years old that got cheated
on 25 or whatever and then one was
married one wasn't if now they're both
30 and in that 10 years they were so
heartbroken couldn't date anyone else
they're now 30 with a child one was
married one wasn't you would go for the
pardon their last over then pudding left
over so no so you want to go for either
of them okay why are you getting divorce
for when you got married why are you
getting divorcedure
situations
no I said both were 20 one was married
one wasn't they both had a child each
one they both were cheated on and then
after 10 5 10 years or whatever now
they're ready to date again because they
couldn't date when they had a young baby
or whatever now the charge is five six
seven eight years old too young today
and they're sorry that's too young
what's Too Young have you got a child
five years old and you've been married
you guys are adding extra stuff like
just I'm trying to get to your reality
she's being from reality
now that the the two women that one was
20 both were 20 one was married one
wasn't whatever they've now come to 26
27 8 whatever years old you're saying
that the one that was married that
divorced she's more valuable than the
one that wasn't I'm just trying to
imagine yeah yeah and you would date the
one that so you would still go for that
one with a child who was divorced
can we stop acting like like men are out
here cheating all the time the majority
of them
I'm saying I'm saying the majority of
men aren't even having sex
guys wait and the wait wait and the
number one reason for divorce is
financial reasons
the conversation that was happening
before you gave a scenario of two women
one both 21 one divorce one dealer I
didn't give that stuff yeah
I was trying to make another Point like
if the men got the most valuable women
ever because she was young pretty
whatever why they still
leave those women if they are they do
they do because I know quite a lot of
single mother so they've been left alone
so for those single mothers they've been
left alone been left alone the man leave
or did they choose the men the men the
men yeah
I like honestly speaking like I am very
close I am very close no very close
relationships also like people that I
know very closely that like they coming
from a divorce parents and she was the
first like she was the Virgin we're
talking about he had two children and
then after he left for Waffle honestly
speaking so like what we talking about
man anyway can get even the best women
ever the most valuable that we're
talking about whatever in our best she
can give him her Best Buy
by and large it's not true the women are
leaving it's not men okay
you're I honestly I came next time I'm
gonna come with number two so probably
I'm gonna improve my the stories that
you have are probably the exception the
huge that's quite a lot there's quite a
lot of single patterns single mother
quite a lot yeah quite a lot probably
like 15 15 or more by a lot yeah and
that's a of my new amount to the whole
thing and so what they're saying is I
see more divorce divorced couples
in your in your circle would you say men
left more than women yeah definitely
from people that you know yeah more than
women yeah yep and the thing is that a
lot of women don't fail to realize is
how hard it is for a man to get married
in the first place but not take that
lightly may not take it lightly and I
don't think they realize the importance
that every man decides to put a ring on
your finger he can have 15 women out
there he decided to put a ring on your
finger that means something because
marriage does not come easy to manage
command decides that's who I'm gonna
marry that puts you up there wherever
you think Webbie's got 15 women or not
but that person out there because
they're married men are risking losing
everything like men men
no men are risking ruin their ruining
their entire life if they marry you
because you can leave take half their
[__] and take the kids with you and then
they have to pay you to take their kids
yeah because they don't even mind
probably about their children sometimes
is that is that what you think of man
some of them yes because if you want to
build a real relationship you gonna
you're gonna look for someone that
actually can deal with everything and
when I'm saying everything I don't mean
cheating because loyalty is actually on
the basement of every relationship men
have lost their entire life savings
trying to get custody of their kids from
mothers that I know because like me
personally I know but I had two brothers
and they've been they coming from the
first my my dad first marriage so I know
quite well so I'm talking about
something that I actually be involved
during my life so I know what I'm
talking about and I'm saying that's
that's such a high risk for a guy so if
a guy is putting a real willing to put a
ring on your finger that means something
like you just took actually the right uh
example because like my dad had two
children from a woman who was the Virgin
we're talking about she was 18 years old
when she met my dad and they had two two
children and the marriage end up right
and my dad actually fight to you know
see the children all right so you see
even though she was the most like I mean
obviously considering your standard so
your standard guys she was a very
valuable girl but anyway the marriage
end up and who win I will say no one
definitely my brothers they suffer quite
a lot but she didn't win because she had
the ring because after my dad married
another my mother and then then she kept
it actually actually yeah that's that's
horrible yeah this is horrible win so
she won because she had the ring who won
in this story
did she just means she won more than the
girl who never got the ring it doesn't
mean she won in life the one who wins is
the one yeah
the one who wins is the one who gets
married and stays married no I I think
she had a very very sad life because you
know when you get that angry to take
your children from your ex-usband you
having a very hard time you have enough
very sad life even though you got the
ring you got [__] you got [__] okay as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible